welcome everyone to my ninth and final
recap from the Qatar Masters uh round
nine finished about an hour ago and I
have a fun game in store to share so
let's hop into it I was playing a pretty
young player from Turkey uh tarhan Adar
fed Master but well over 2400 uh I think
he's an IM am elect so should be getting
the international Master title very soon
and coming into this game I didn't have
like so much time to prepare because the
round started a couple hours earlier but
I did have a kind of new interesting
opening idea to try out and I started
with Pawn to E4 and I was expecting Pawn
E5 and we went into a four Knight Scotch
after Knight C3 Knight F6 and D4 and
this is an opening I've played from both
sides basically since childhood and it's
a very popular opening across all levels
usually when you see this opening at a
higher level it indicates that white is
playing for a draw um but I chose this
opening because it's a very safe option
it's very solid and knowing myself uh I
do get tired towards the end of the
tournament so I wanted something that
was solid and not something too crazy
for the final game and after takes takes
Bishop to B4 this is all the main line
trade on C6 Bishop D3 and pawn to D5 and
this position if we look in the Master's
database has been reached uh well over
3,000 times and the most common move by
far in this position is Pawn takes Pawn
but that's not the move that I played
and the other reason that I went for
this specific variation was to throw a
surprise at my opponent uh in this
position with the move Bishop to D2 and
this is a very rare move played only 3%
of the time uh but it is a tricky way of
playing this position and I think Bishop
D2 has become a bit trendier in recent
times uh there's been a good number of
grand Masters who have tried this uh now
it does have a very high draw percentage
and I knew this going into the game that
it's very possible if my opponent's
prepared we could just go straight to
the end game and uh and draw pretty
quickly
but given that I was a low rated player
coming into this game I was hoping to
maybe provoke my opponent to over push
so we will see what happens after my
opponent castles I castle and then my
opponent pretty quickly here played Rook
to E8 which surprised me a little bit
because it's not the primary move in
this position and yeah going back to the
database here we can see that Rook B8 is
the most common move followed by Bishop
C3 three and Rook E8 still a playable
move but it gives white uh a very
interesting option which I went for now
I want to take a moment to explain one
of the critical main lines that black
can go for is Bishop takes C3 and I was
ready to go into this line after takes
takes takes takes takes takes Rook B8
Rook B1 uh takes takes takes takes this
would not have been the most exciting of
openings basically going straight from
the opening into the end game uh this
position has pretty high draw percentage
but white does have a microscopic edge
here given that The Rook is more active
and I thought if we enter this then it's
basically a two result game I can try
and grind out the ending or it would
just uh be a draw but it's only white
playing for a win here so thankfully
that did not happen the game took a more
interesting route and uh my opponent did
did play Rook to E8 um now this move
does allow white to have a pretty nice
idea which I was prepared for is Knight
takes
D5 and it's a crazy looking tactical
shot but uh the tactics do work for
white mainly because this bishop on B4
is undefended and this should explain
why Rook B8 is the more common move here
defending the bishop and basically
preventing Knight takes D5 uh what
happened in the game my opponent allowed
Knight takes D5 and then after takes
takes takes we get to a position where
it's still equal material but I do have
the bishop pair and um I thought that
white is still probably a little bit
better here uh now I wasn't specifically
prepared for Knight takes E4 I did have
this position on my computer before the
game and I was prepared for Bishop to B5
Bishop D7 and then take I think the
engine will give like a small Edge for
white but after Knight takes E4 I was on
my own but uh position looks very solid
and I just make a a simple improving
move Rook to E1 pressuring the Knight on
e4 and then my opponent responds with
Queen to G5 and then I had a decision to
make um because I I really wanted to
keep my Bishop pair but I was really
drawn to this move Bishop takes E4
and I spent a long think here trying to
decide do I go for Bishop takes Knight
or do I try and play something else but
if I play a move like F3 I could get hit
with Bishop to
H3 so ultimately I did decide to
concede my light Square bishop and after
Pawn takes I played the move Rook to
E3 uh now I want to take a small pause
on what happened in this game cuz I want
to share a slightly different variation
for my pregame prep now let's keep this
position in mind and I'm actually just
going to open a new chapter here and I
want to
share uh basically what was another line
in my preparation in this exact Bishop
D2 line let's just get to the position
Bishop D2 and after castle castle there
is a move I was prepared for in this
position which was Bishop takes C3
Bishop takes C3 and Knight takes E4 and
this is one of the positions I I was
looking at pretty deeply before the game
um if we were to wind up in this line
white is down a pawn but I was prepared
with idea Queen H5 and then the middle
game idea of Rook E1 to E3 to G3 and the
reason why I'm showing this is because
we got a very similar structure in our
game if we go back to to where I left
off uh basically I already got my Rook
to E3 and I have ideas of Bishop C3 and
Rook G3 and there's a lot of attacking
potential for white um now if we compare
this to the line I Was preparing uh
White is down a pawn in this position so
I knew that white is for Choice
according to engine in this position and
I basically made the assumption that in
this position white should definitely be
for choice given that I'm not down upon
and I have all the same ideas and even
though it's obos clar Bishops which
maybe sometimes have a drawing tendency
uh my Bishop should be more of a weapon
than black Bishop but going forward from
here uh things do get a bit complicated
because my opponent is the first to
seize initiative with Bishop to G4 and I
had to be very careful here because if I
play a move let's say like Queen D4 then
black can get in Bishop F3 and my rook's
not coming to G3 my Pawn would have to
come to G3 and then black is ready to
invade on the light squares so after
Bishop G4 uh I had another choice to
make and I was actually very close to
playing the move Rook to G3 which I
think is like the safest line for white
after takes takes takes black
temporarily goes up a pawn but then I
would have Rook C5 and I thought that
white is probably slightly better going
into this end game with a more active
rook and maybe this Pawn could be
weakness also Bishop C3 still coming um
but the more I thought about my options
I realized that the better way to play
for win is to keep Queens on the board
and not play Rook G3 but rather play the
move Queen F1 and with this move I'm
basically preemptively defending my G2
Pawn so in the vent of Bishop f three I
can simply play King H1 and my Pawn's
defended The Bishop's attacked and this
really doesn't lead to anything for
black so after Queen F1 I'm basically
just trying to keep the tension in the
position put the ball back in my
opponent's courtz and my opponent uh
played a very aggressive move here Pawn
to F5 and this is a uh somewhat of a
committal move because this Pawn can't
go backwards and I do have potential
later on to play Bishop C3 and The
Bishop's going to be uncontested on the
diagonal given the pawn can't go back to
F6 um but of course for the time being
F5 does have the idea of f4 maybe later
F3 or E3 so I had to be really really
careful here and the move I played in
this position I thought was a nice
prophylactic move Rook a to E1 very
simply preventing F4 because now this
Pawn is tied down to defending E4 and I
thought that after Rook ae1 it's not so
easy for black to make progress with any
sort of attack but my opponent did try
to keep the pressure he played Queen to
G6 and this does defend the rook and
have more defense uh on e4 so this
basically does prepare Pawn F4 and I
still had to be very careful here so I
play the move Queen to C4 check and
after Rook E6 I play King to H1 uh just
making sure that there's no funny
business on along the G file uh no more
Bishop F3 and yeah after King H1 I think
it's black who is now under a lot of
pressure given that The Rook is pinned
to the king there's ideas of F3 or H3
and the pawns on light squares don't
really combine well with Black's light
Square Bishop so going forward from here
my opponent plays Rook E8 defending uh
The Rook on E6 I play Pawn H3 and then
my opponent played a move which I did
not see coming at all like this move
caught me by surprise Queen F7 uh
essentially saying oh no my Bishop um
yeah this is how pawns move by the way
like a knight and then over one but uh
yeah if I take the bishop I would then
lose my queen so I did not want to take
the poison and after Queen F7 I I took a
bit of a think and realized that I just
have a pretty
nice move Rook to C3 defending my queen
now threatening to take the bishop and
also creating a battery against a C7
Pawn I think once I played Rook C3 uh
black is under major major pressure um
but my opponent still tried to keep
things complicated he played the move
Queen to H5 and I still had to be very
careful here because if I take the pawn
then I think there's some is there like
Bishop F3 with ideas of Queen takes H3
long story short I was too scared to
take the pawn on C7 but um I found a
really nice simple move here King to G1
and this move basically traps the bishop
because now my Pawn is no longer pinned
and the only safe Square for the bishop
is Bishop D1 but then I would have Queen
D5 and yeah The Bishop's just a goner
here so when I played King G1 I had
actually calculated the line that ended
up happening in the game so going
forward from here my opponent play King
h8 uh gives me the bishop after takes
it's still not super simple because
black wants to just Checkmate me on the
H file that was a reason for King h8 to
unpin the Rook from E6 but I saw this
position coming and I had a nice
defensive idea here starting with Queen
C5 simp simply offering the queen trade
and basically in this position all I
need to do is not get M and not give
back material and I'll be up a bishop uh
but my opponent of course avoids the
queen trade he plays Queen H4 and in
this position I played a sequence which
I had seen coming from when I played
King G1 it's starting with Pawn G3
provoking Queen H3 and then really nice
uh kind of geometrical move Queen B5
and I was very happy to see this move
from a distance because not only do I
want to come back and just defend my
king with Queen F1 but I also am tying
down this Rook Black's not in time to
play Rook H6 because I just take on E8
and Checkmate so the square actually was
very very useful for my queen and once I
played this move I pretty much figured
that I'm I'm winning and my opponent
played Pawn C5 as a last Stitch effort
maybe hoping I would take with the queen
so then Rook H6 is much more deadly but
I took with the bishop and after he
played Queen H5 I play Queen F1 and he
resigned and that concludes the
tournament uh I did finish with a win
after what I think was a very clean game
uh in in the final round uh now I
haven't had a chance to analyze with the
engine yet but but overall I'm very
pleased with uh just how this game went
um especially given the the opening
surprise I got kind of the early
pressure against my opponent in the
opening and I weathered his kingside
storm and came out uh up material and
and got the win so as usual let's check
with the engine okay so I did make one
inaccuracy this game but uh I was never
worse and let's just check the the early
stage yeah so Knight takes D5 was all
pregame preparation engine slightly
prefers White and the line we went
into so Queen G5 was my opponent's like
first big
inaccuracy and wow so apparently here I
did have
F3 it's funny I like I briefly
considered this during the game and then
then Ben fold was in my mind just
telling me never play F3
and then rather than calculating the
lines I just listen to Ben fold so what
happens after Bishop H3 Rook E2 is it
really that simple Knight
moves oh Bishop D2 ah the bishop gets
stuck wow so black has to do something
crazy like C5 but then take take take
and White's just much better
here okay yeah I should have I should
have disciplined myself to calculate F3
a bit more thoroughly so my one mistake
was taking on e4 but I played this move
cuz it was so similar to the the other
opening variation I prepare and then
going forward from here Queen
F1 I think this is all very
clean so what what was my opponent's
blunder ah Queen
H5 yeah Queen H5 just got the bishop
trapped maybe my opponent didn't see
like my defensive idea with Queen B5 in
that line so appar black had to play
Bishop
H5 but then yeah then I can take on C7
and life is very good for white so okay
uh a nice way to end the tournament um
what more to say but thanks everyone for
watching my recaps I really appreciate
all the positive energy and the YouTube
comments also really appreciate people
tuning in to the twitch channel uh big
thank you to Jonathan TR taking over
every single game I think he woke up at
like 5:00 a.m.
central time today to cover this game so
it was great to have just such a nice
Community following my games um I do
want to show the final standings of the
tournament I'll just go to chess results
here apologies for the light mode but I
just want to show the rating gain I
wasn't really looking at this so closely
during the tournament um apologies for
the the slightly scuffed layout but this
is um this is a chess results link it's
linked in every YouTube description in
my recaps but basically we can see my um
my overall score I finished with five
out of nine which was pretty nice
considering every single opponent was
about a 100 points or more higher rated
than me um played everyone 2400 plus and
I am gaining about 20 rating points from
this tournament and I did have a
performance rating over 2500 so um I
think this is one of my best
performances of all time it's definitely
been a long time since I've had a
performance rating this high in a
classical event so very pleased uh we
can see the overall standings games
still might be going as I record this
but oh wow so we can see Abdu satarov
maybe winning the tournament there might
be still a game going though yeah
there's still some games going uh yaku
boev might catch up if he wins so if we
just see the overall standings as of now
um where did Magnus finish oh is Magnus
still playing I think Magnus is still
playing too so okay real quick how's
Magnus Carlson
doing Magnus is
losing Magnus had like a terrible
opening today um I don't want to go too
deep down the rabbit hole of what
happened in magnus's game but like
during so during the uh the round I was
taking a glance at mag mag's position I
saw the position after Rook G8 and he
was actually just walking around the
playing Hall like laughing and I think
he was just laughing at how bad his
position was so yeah somehow he like he
survived though and then he was
better yeah he was like for choice in
this middle
game then he was completely winning
[Music]
somehow but then
something oh he just made a terrible
Wonder Bishop
C4 allowing some
[Music]
simplification I mean still have drawing
chances but White's up two
pawns wow and White's winning with King
B2 or King
A2 um I don't think I'm going to wait
and until the game finishes but yeah if
Magnus loses this game then that means I
I finish half a point behind Magnus
which uh I guess is some sort of
achievement Magnus losing a lot of
rating this tournament but anyway um I
don't want to make this video too long
so uh big thanks again to everyone
watching uh do stay tuned for maybe some
different type of content coming up I do
hope to return soon to Twitch and maybe
return also to the speedrun series as
well so stay tuned and I'll see you guys
soon